it's really fun to be here I changed the
title of my talk so I hope that's not
too much of a shock for you guys so I'm
calling it crowdsourcing for machine
learning and why am I doing that because
I think everywhere I go is like
everything is seems to be machine
learning these days even on NPR I can't
like there's not a companies that's not
doing machine learning Big Data cloud
whatever and so machine learning is
great and is all about getting data lots
and lots of data and in fact that's led
to a huge rise in crowdsourcing with a
number of different labor platforms out
there and there's like one thing that
people seem to forget when they use
crowdsourcing to get machine learning
and sjg training data and that is that
the data that we tend to get is actually
used for two different purposes so one
purpose is training data which of course
is what you need most of the data for
and the other one is test data or
validation data and with the data that's
used for test and validation the
accuracy of the data is super important
which leads to lots of people trying to
do really high quality annotation and
sometimes get multiple people annotating
the same examples and using majority
vote or expectation-maximization to come
up with the most accurate labels when
you're actually creating training data
that can be a mistake because really
don't care about the accuracy of the
training data we carry about what the
accuracy of the resulting classifier so
what I'm going to do today is talk about
a number of different crowd sourcing
techniques some of them are specially
good for getting accurate data some of
them are more emphasized on just how do
we actually train a good machine
learning classifier so that's the two
halves of the talk not quite halves the
first part is is a little bit longer so
I'll be talking about a couple different
techniques for generating really
accurate data one is by using decision
theory another one is by getting workers
to argue with each other
and the third one is trying to get the
workers to actually improve the
instructions
of the workflow that they're using
themselves and then the final a bit in
the talk is going to be about something
called reactive learning which is a
crowdsourcing technique that's
specifically aimed at building
high-quality classifiers okay so I'll
start out by talking about decision
theory and I'm going to use an arbitrary
workflow to explain this is actually the
iterative improvement workflow from Greg
littles PhD thesis that Lydia helped
develop so here the basic idea is you
have some sort of initial artifact could
be captured for an image and maybe you
ask a worker to improve it and then you
go out to some other workers and you say
which of these two captions is better
then you take the better one and you
either give it out or else you send it
back through to to get it improved more
and in Greg's thesis started out for
example with the captioning task here's
a picture that's what the crowd worker
came up with is the first explanation a
first caption for the image and after
going around eight iterations getting a
much much better caption it's really
pretty cool the crowdsourcing can do
this kind of stuff but this is Greg's
thesis so I will skip after it and just
point out that while this is really
powerful there's a whole set of
questions that Greg didn't really answer
one is um how many times should you how
many people should you have vote on
which of these two captions is better
before you go around the loop and how
many times should you go around the loop
and Greg used some pretty terroristic
techniques for the votes what he did was
he got two different votes and if they
agreed he figured that was the right
answer and if they disagreed he got a
third vote to disambiguate took majority
vote and went around and then just went
around the loop the same number of times
every time pretty simple approach but
what I want to address is can we do
better by actually varying those varying
those answers to those questions so I'm
going to think about using decision
theory to figure out what's the best
thing to ask the crowd worker to do so
the crowd worker we could ask them to to
vote on two different captions we could
ask them to go ahead and improve
whatever we think is
best caption so far or we could just
decide we're done as well as we can
let's just submit the final the final
result so I'm going to teach this treat
this as an AI as an AI planning problem
so in AI typically we've got an AI
system and agent that's interacting with
the environment here the environment um
is giving percepts and that's going to
be the result of the crowd workers
efforts and the actions are to ask
people to do things for the agent and to
control things we're going to use a
partially observable Markov decision
process so let me just do AI Ciolino got
mostly an HDI audience I'm going to just
go very very briefly over what Markov
decision processes are so here we've got
a world state suppose is for a robot
moving around in a 2d environment we've
got a set of actions and what the
actions is it says suppose we're in some
state and we execute an action and we've
got a probability distribution over
where the robot is going to end up which
is visually shown where that pink region
there and some cost for the action and
then after the robot actually does the
motion we get to observe exactly where
the robot is and we get some sort of
some sort of reward and the objective is
to come up with a policy which tells the
robot always what to do given from state
what action should I execute that's
going to maximize the expected
discounted reward of all of the rewards
we're going to achieve over time so
that's an MDP and people should ask
questions if anybody's got questions
please speak up at any time we're going
to use and write this is easy if you
know what those probability
distributions are and what the rewards
are but typically what we do is we don't
know that so we want to learn them as
we're actually generating that policy on
what I actually want to use is a special
kind of MD code T called a partially
observable MVP and it's got the same the
same thing except we start out with a
probability distribution over the state
we don't know actually where the robot
is just where it probably is we've got
the same action model but actually after
we execute an action we get instead of
seeing where the where the robot is
exactly we get
to have a noisy sensor reading which
allows us to come up with an improved
probability distribution but we still
don't know exactly the state of the
system and we're still trying to come up
with a policy and we're still doing that
while we're learning the action model so
this is upon DP okay so that sort of
makes sense in the context of robot so
let me explain how it works for
crowdsourcing with crowdsourcing so
instead of having actions like moving
and grasping we've got actions like
improve the caption or vote which of the
two captions is better the state space
instead of being an XY coordinate for
the for the robot we we still use a
state space in this case of two of two
real numbers and they're basically
representing the quality of the first
caption and the quality of the second
caption so our numbers have to between 0
and 1 instead of having a sonar what we
get all we get to observe is what's the
result of the most recent vote and the
reward is well we have a negative reward
every time we pay a worker but we get a
positive reward for returning a good
caption at the end so that's the pond EP
the Palm DP model and just to give an
illustration so here's what happens when
a worker creates a new artifact so we
might have some distribution shown at
the top that says you know we think the
the capture is not so good and after we
ask a worker to create the new artifact
well then maybe we've got expectation
that the caption is quite a bit better
and here if we've got two different
captions and we've got distributions
over both of them and we ask a worker
which one's better supposing the worker
says that the first one artifact one is
better then that gives us on these two
different distributions so basically
that means that either this caption is
better or else this caption is worse and
so we update both of those probability
distributions and we learn these models
over time ok so that's how any questions
so far
ok
there's a bunch of AI techniques for
solving these things they all revolve
around Bellman's equations and
fundamentals of reinforcement learning
and solving this exploration
exploitation trade-off and I'm going to
skip over all of these techniques
because they're more AI techniques than
HDI techniques here's the results when
we applied this and compared it to the
model that Greg the Greg used so first
of all with upon DP we were able to
generate much higher quality captions
for the same for the same cost or if we
control for every control for the
quality then we're able to generate them
a much reduced cost so 30% less labor
and that's kind of cool what's more
interesting though is actually what the
system does so this is what this is what
Greg system did and notice how many
iterations were going over and also no
notice how many votes are happening
roughly it's like two and a half votes
right that's because you went out and
asked two workers and if they agreed he
stopped otherwise the system added a
third asked a third person to
disambiguate what our system did was
this and when I first saw that I thought
that there was a bug in the code and
then we realized system actually is
being very very smart it's not wasting
any votes at the beginning because it's
just assuming that the worker probably
did improve the caption and it's only
after you've had a whole bunch of people
improving the caption that it starts
getting hard to make it any better so
that's where it started allocating more
and more of the effort to try to figure
out what's the best caption as a result
it's able to make better decisions over
here and also able to go out for four
more iterations and that's why it came
up with better better captions so so
that's kind of cool yeah all right that
reasoning robot yeah like the training
part pause yeah so this work that I'm
describing here sort of as a preamble to
the rest of the stuff as things we did
quite a few years ago now we actually
learned the probability models using
supervised learning so
had a separate set of tasks where we
learn them so in these experiments we
did an offline learning process to learn
the probability models what we did in
the subsequent work and so all the other
things I'll be talking about after this
are all done with reinforcement learning
so as you're actually executing the
workflow you use expectation
maximization to build up these these
models of what the actions are doing and
explaining the details takes a little
bit of time so happy to do that
afterwards episode 2 the reason
potential exists so let me let me give
you an illustration with the
reinforcement learning approaches we're
coming up a slightly different task but
it it answers that question directly ok
so I want to get back to annotating
training data because loss of my NLP
colleagues at UW are especially
interested in doing this so the problem
of course is that annotators make
mistakes and so what most people tend to
do is they they filter out with with
gold questions they ask workers to do
the same thing multiple times as we saw
before they aggregate with expectation
maximization they pay lots and lots of
money and still they tend to be
disappointed with with the results but
let's just look at one of these things
so one way of making sure that your
entertainers are doing a good job is to
ask them questions where you know the
answer already and see whether they get
the answer right question is like how
many questions these questions we
already know the answer are called gold
questions how many of the gold questions
should you insert and just picking a
couple papers from actually two of them
were done here at Stanford and people do
all sorts of different things
13% gold and filter them as they get
less than a 67 percent accuracy rating
or whatever you can see that there's a
complicated set of parameters to figure
out to try to balance off and people
oftentimes do a bunch of studies at the
beginning to try to figure out whether
they're getting the the data right and
and so on but
the bottom line is not only is it a
hassle to come up with these parameter
values but there really is no right
answer to that question it's much better
not to have a static policy but instead
be adaptive to the workers and how the
workers are behaving as things are
actually getting because maybe at
different times a day you need to have a
different different policy
yeah that could be TAS differences here
more so than worker differences on the
previous line
well more here in this case like oh it
has differences I think yeah some
problems are going to be much much
harder and so maybe you want to make
maybe you need to be testing the workers
more so so I agree I don't think even
within a single task there's an optimal
set of parameter values but but I think
that it's really going to change between
the past as you're suggesting which is
why it's so hard to come up with the
right values and again like what
CrowdFlower says is you know put in 20%
of all the tasks you ask workers should
you should be test questions where you
already know the answer Wow well that's
actually wasting a lot of money if you
know especially now if you want them
other people to do it three times and
it's really kind of kind of crazy okay
so it shouldn't be a surprise that what
I'm proposing is that what we should do
is give out these these tests adaptively
and we can use upon VP to figure out to
figure out how to do it so the basic
idea is we basically say what accuracy
do we want the actual data to be we
provide a bunch of gold questions and a
base policy which could be the
CrowdFlower default policy of putting in
twenty percent gold and then the system
has got a series of questions so I could
ask a test question I could ask a real
question where I care about the answer
or I could just tell the worker sorry
don't want to work with you anymore and
get another person to take that person's
place on and then obviously if I've
asked a test question I get an
observation about whether they do the
right the right answer and sometimes the
workers the workers may leave and the
reward is to maximize the expected value
you of the work questions which is kind
of weird because we actually can't
observe what the reward is because we
don't know the answers to those
questions okay so again we use
reinforcement learning the state space
is really simple we basically have a
model about how skilled the worker is
and also what we call diligence which
means even skilled workers may stop
paying attention and just start slacking
off so it's the cross-product of those
two different spaces and we start out
with the base policy again the sort of
CrowdFlower default policy and then use
sort of a pretty simple exploration
exploitation policy where we're using
Epsilon greedy but we're decreasing the
epsilon value as you spend more and more
of your budget that makes the system
explore a lot at the beginning and then
start doing it's learned optimal policy
afterwards and here's an example of what
we see so as we start asking questions
we're doing just as well as the base
grabs our policy and then the system
learns a better policy and as it
switches over to that it starts being
much more efficient with its resources
and the thing that's super great about
this is it doesn't matter really what
the optimal settings are because it's
going to figure out given what the
workers are doing what what really the
best policy should be so maybe you
should be more strict than CrowdFlower
may should be more lenient and maybe
with some workers should be asking more
questions than others so that's an AMS
paper and then we also extended the
model to put in adaptive learning as
well so like how much should we teach
the worker how to actually do the task
and what was really disappointing about
that was that the policy the pond GP
learned was really simple it was
basically keep teaching them and
correcting them on their results until
they get a certain number of answers
correct in a row which is like what Khan
Academy does and like the obvious policy
so you don't need a pond DP for that our
pond BP did maybe a tiny tiny bit better
but it wasn't wasn't interesting
you know after well that's why we
stopped doing the research is like well
that seems like a pretty obvious policy
as what we've seen is very consistent
behavior like there's certainly like
sort of a little coupe up at the
beginning as I'm learning how to do
something but after that you actually
have a pretty good feed on key it's not
clear like from our experiences that I
can really shift you one way or another
so you may just be that very quickly you
can get a good signal men look - go man
um I think that's a result I think
different people take different amounts
of time to actually learn the task but
again that policy of teaching them and
and correcting them when they make a
mistake so that they actually learn what
the task is until they get K correct in
a row which demonstrates they actually
understand what they're supposed to be
doing that really simple policy works
well no matter how quick a learner they
are interactive tailoring literature to
think about like where we test which
which trainings are we getting over you
can give you more and more difficult
training examples as we go sort of
scaffold you up absolutely and obviously
people in the education literature have
looked at similar kinds of pom GP models
there of course what they're really
trying to do is make sure that they're
maximizing for education whereas in this
model we're trying to maximize for
getting the most work done at a high
quality and education by itself is not
is not so important or interesting okay
so that's one method now I want to
switch to something completely different
and that is getting workers to argue
with each other
so I'm going to introduce a bunch of a
task a relation annotation task and I
need to tell you a little bit about the
task because there's actually a really
hard task and it doesn't sound that hard
but what we're trying to do is determine
whether that not that natural language
sentence United States need to be ready
to press compromise proposal something
Bush in a secretary
Condoleezza Rice show very little
interest in doing question is from that
sentence can we deduce that Bush lived
in the United States in NLP we're
interested in reading these natural
language sentences and then building up
a knowledge base of all of of all of the
facts that are entailed one fact might
be to somebody live someplace and part
of the problem is that the text analytic
conference which runs a competition on
how well your natural language
processing system does has very
complicated rules about what lived-in
means so for example first of all the
fact I know that George Bush live the
United States is not enough I have to be
able to deduce it from the sentence
secondly if somebody works in a location
that tak annotator people said well that
doesn't let you that's not enough
information to conclude that they
actually lived there because they may be
computing and commuting from someplace
else on the other hand if you're a
national official then you can conclude
that you worked in that city in that
country and so on there's a bunch of
other rules and so to get high-quality
data you need to learn all of these all
of these rules and some of these
sentences are kind of tricky and what we
notice is on these hard problems if you
do the standard majority vote oftentimes
the majority gets the answer wrong and
maybe there's only one person in the
group that gets the answer right and so
our thought was well maybe instead of
just aggregating by voting we should
have the workers argue with each other
and maybe one person can convince all
the others that that he or she was right
and that's way the day we could get
higher accuracy that way so these
problems are hard as I said random is a
binary question would get fifty percent
right we using majority vote you get
fifty-nine percent right using
expectation-maximization weighted
majority vote you get sixty-five percent
right that's pathetic right I mean it's
really really bad results the question
is can we do better and hopefully
argumentation is going to let us do
better so voting is bad we don't like
voting doesn't give us the results we
like so let's instead argue and see who
sounds to be the best
and basic idea here is inspired by the
talk pages on Wikipedia where people
make have a discussion about exactly
what they should be doing and the
question is can we actually put that
into a micro task context and have these
little discussions that are very focused
and and lead to better answers so we
come up with a set of primitive tasks
one is actually not new the standard
annotation task is like given some
judgment market would you think it's
true or false
whatever another one is well now that
you've decided is true can you explain a
logical argument for why that's the case
that's the justified task and then the
final task is a reconsider task so if
the posing I say the answer is true I
now want to have the system is not going
to present me a counter-argument that is
arguing the opposite position and I get
to see whether I want to change my mind
after seeing that that argument so
that's the basic that's the basic set up
and so here's an example of the workflow
we start out with an assess task they
say false and they they give their their
assessment and now they justify and
explain why they think that answer is
false
so we ask them what the reason is they
write something down another worker
comes in they say true and they justify
with a different explanation and then we
go back and we connect these two workers
asynchronously and we ask them if they
want to change their mind do they change
their mind and hopefully get a better
result then as more workers come in we
can do this
better and better so what's the hope the
hope is that we've got a whole bunch of
people get the answers wrong and one
person who gets the answer right and we
hope that they're all going to switch
over to the other side to give us the
better answer furthermore we hope we can
do this without too much cost overhead
from all of the arguing maybe we don't
need to argue every time unfortunately
this is what we actually experienced was
that the bad people
with the wrong arguments we're just as
good at convincing other people and so
there was like a tiny improvement in
accuracy but basically it was a complete
miserable failure so that was very
disappointing but luckily we were able
to figure out a fix and that was
basically to filter the workflow so that
we only allowed people to do the
reconsider tasks if their justifications
were sophisticated we call them
discerning workers so I've got a
caricature here but basically what we
did is we looked at the school the flesh
Kincaid readability scores of what the
workers wrote as they're going through
the training process and if their
explanations were really kind of simple
then that was a clue to us that maybe
they they're writing simple explanations
maybe they can't really understand
complicated justifications so let's not
include those people in the study let's
just conclude the others so after doing
that filtering test we end up doing much
much better so here's the standard
results 65% with e/m 71% with micro
tests so we did get some benefit with
all the workers but if we filter for
just these discerning workers we get up
to 84% which is really much much better
than playing voting at 65 so so this was
very exciting and so in summary here is
the the workflow we've got a training
process assess and then this combination
of justify and reconsider tasks as it's
going forward we made two different
extensions and these are still in
progress but I think they're they're
kind of cool so the first one is in
micro talk what we do is we just select
an explanation a justification randomly
and present that to workers but stands
to reason that a really good
justification is going to be more
convincing than just a randomly selected
justification and we actually wrote our
own justifications and tried that and
you know the accuracy was much much
better so the question is can we somehow
automatically find these best
justifications or create them quickly
and then use that to make the system
work better and so we tried again using
a reinforcement learning technique and
we are in fact able to find that much
more convincing explanations in our
system shows those much more frequently
as you can see green means it's a really
persuasive argument and the height shows
how many times we're showing it so we're
able to pretty quickly find the best
explanations which is pretty cool
it took us longer than we had hoped and
so I'm not convinced that this is really
a practical thing going forward the
other thing is in the original system
when I come up with an argument I write
my justification the counter-argument I
see is just as randomly selected or
maybe as a good justification but it has
nothing to do with what I actually wrote
as my argument be much better if I got
something that was customized
specifically to my argument maybe
pointing out a hole in my argument so
what we did was try to build a
synchronous workflow that lined workers
up so that they could debate with each
other about the individual merits of
their own of their own arguments and Jim
Chen built this kind of cool chat
interface with a real-time real-time
crowd-sourced workflow that actually
does this and we see they be getting
much more focused focused arguments but
we're not sure whether but it's also
more expensive to actually bring workers
together in real time so it's not clear
that there's going to be as much payoff
as we'd hoped for the other thing we do
is after they have an argument that come
to an agreement then we ask them to go
back and revise their justification so
that we can use it going forward so this
brings me to the next the next part of a
talk which is thinking about how we can
make these workflows actually improve
themselves maybe we can have not just on
the justifications but the whole
structure of the workflow or maybe the
instructions of the
floo we can get the crowd workers to
make these things work better so as
motivation I want to pull out a paper
that I did is actually a natural
language processing paper but again
we're trying to do relation extraction
and when most people do is they for
relation extraction is it's too
expensive to actually go out there and
ask grad workers to annotate everything
so they use a method called distance
supervision to generate heuristic alee
heuristic training examples which are
kind of low-quality but they're better
than random and actually allow the
system to learn something pretty well
and a natural question seemed to be
because did some of the early work on
distance supervision maybe I could
combine these two different methods and
infuse use mostly distance supervision
but infuse the distantly supervised
training data with a little bit of
crowdsource data and get much better
results and so I decided to start
working on that and the first thing I
did was a literature survey and
importantly I found that three people
had already written papers on the topic
so that was really disappointing but
then I looked at the results and they
all concluded it didn't work they
concluded that if we get the crowd
workers to actually provide more hand
labelled data it actually doesn't help
over-over this really crummy heuristic
it just seemed really weird so we looked
more carefully and why their results
were bad and the reason the results were
bad was because their training data was
really bad and they you know they
basically hadn't hadn't taught the
workers how to do the task very well and
so the accuracy was about the exact same
as this definitely supervised training
data so we thought more about how to
actually do it and came up with a method
called gated instruction but it's sounds
kind of complicated is really based on
two key points first one is that workers
don't read the instructions and write I
mean they just want to get on with the
task so the natural thing is we need to
force them to read the instruction by
making so they can't actually progress
in the workflow until they demonstrated
actually read the instructions and
understand
and when the second thing is when people
write these instructions usually they do
a crummy job and and so the workers are
legitimately confused about what they're
supposed to do so the obvious takeaway
here is you should polish those
instructions and make them really clear
and I think if that just takes so long
it's really a pain in the neck most
people doing crowdsourcing don't want to
actually do that so so that leads to the
question can we get the crowd to
actually do that for us so again here's
sort of a standard workflow is we might
start out with some instructions and ask
the worker teach the worker how to do
the task and then we're going to
evaluate them to make sure that they
really do understand the task and if not
we'll go back and teach them some more
and then we'll go out and actually get
some work done what we're proposing and
this is Jonathan Briggs PhD thesis is a
meta workflow which combines actions
from the crowd workers with actions in
the requestor so we're given the
requester a couple micro tasks to do -
one is to diagnose what confusion and
then clarify the instructions so the
idea is come up the initial instructions
we go through this until we detect some
confusions and then we ask the requester
to fix those and we go around that
hopefully in this automated fashion we
can actually do it much faster and much
easier here is as an example so here's
the task mark whether or not the image
below is of a bird seems pretty clear
right you want ask workers is it a bird
or not a bird what could possibly go
wrong
with this question it's so obvious we
should just go off and put our $10,000
budget to get a bunch of birds labeled
well most of the bird pictures you look
at or like pretty clearly birds or not
birds but it's only after you've gone
through a couple hundred examples that
suddenly you come up with that okay is
that a bird or not a bird I don't know
is that really it is a bird but is that
really what you wanted me to label as a
bird what about that is that a bird and
so on you have to see lots and lots of
examples before you get to these corner
cases
so in this workflow we give the initial
instructions an example and we ask the
worker to basically not just say yes or
no but to explain where they are on the
threshold is it a clear-cut case or is
it an ambiguous case and if it's
ambiguous then why are they confused and
then after we've had a bunch of workers
go through it we automatically cluster
the examples based on the descriptions
that people have written and then we go
back to the requester and the requester
sees a set of confusing images and they
have to decide for each of these
clusters is are these positive examples
or negative examples what do I want it
to be and furthermore they have the
instructions there so they can edit the
instructions as they're going so I might
I might write I want it to be a
realistic thing of a living living bird
and put in some more examples and then I
can drag some examples from these
clusters over and have them
automatically inserted into the
instructions to make it really clear and
also drag them over and have them put
into into the test examples that are
part of the gating and instruction
before though workers can go on and I
can do this with all the training with
all the data I've seen so far and then I
can push okay I think I've got it
unambiguous now and then it goes back
and it runs a couple hundred more
workers through through the tasks but
specifically it focuses on the ones that
we're confusing and it picks out a
couple examples from each cluster as
well as a number of other examples
randomly to see whether or not you've
actually diminished the confusion
substantially or not that is that's the
idea and and Jonathan is just as just
starting the user studies on this okay
so he now we're at the the homestretch
of the talk and I'm going to say
something pretty much completely
different so here I want to get away
from
the training data just trying to create
high quality data and instead think
about the larger the larger picture so
what we really want to do is optimize
the behavior of the classifier
independent of the data so why why is
this a different thing
okay I'm repeating repeating myself so
imagine that we're trying to to label
images and so on we've got a budget so
I've got these pictures one choice I
could do is I could get one worker to
annotate each of these examples another
thing I could do is I could go out and
use majority vote or something like that
get three workers to annotate each of
these examples as a result I'm going to
have much higher quality results but
obviously I've got a lot less data so
there's a real question about should we
do this sort of you know labeling thing
or should we actually get multiple votes
and if I'm going to get multiple votes
maybe we should go whole hog and like
have one example and get it really
really accurate okay that's obviously
stupid but it's not really clear what
the right thing to do is in between most
people are actually going out and
getting three labels for every example
but is that really better to to figure
this out we got a bunch of different
data sets and then we simulated noisy
annotations on the data sets and then
ran machine learning algorithm to try to
figure out which of these strategies was
better and what we came up with was this
in half the domains it was much better
to get a single label in another half of
the domain the other half of the domains
it was much better to to get multiple
people annotating things and sometimes
you wanted much more than three
sometimes you wanted as many as seven
people annotating the data so I was very
disheartening I was really hoping it
would be some sort of clear-cut
clear-cut thing and furthermore the
differences are not insignificant so you
really can get much because again this
is the classifier performance so if you
can get a five or a ten percent
improvement in your classifier you know
if you're doing natural language
research that's super exciting and if
all
done is like change the way you're
getting your training data that's much
better than having to go and learn how
to use deep neural networks or something
right okay so what's going on with this
mystery what we came up with eventually
was realizing that there's three factors
that affect what strategy you should be
using and the first one is what's the
inductive bias of your classifier
specifically what's the VC dimension of
your classifier which is sort of a proxy
for what's the dimensionality of your
classifier if you've got a high
dimensional classifier that's you know
either many many features and it's a
linear or maybe it's a nonlinear
classifier like a deep neural network
then relabeling is much more important
and the reason why is the classifier is
much more able to overfit to errors in
the training data the second question is
is worker accuracy and it turns out that
relabeling is most important when your
workers are just right in the middle and
it turns out if your workers are really
bad then it doesn't really matter what
you do if your workers are perfect then
clearly what you want to do is you know
label because you're getting perfect
labels so there's no benefit but here
workers are right in the middle you can
get a pretty big boost by doing by doing
relabeling so it's not clear yet you
can't decide what to do just based on
what your worker accuracy is but all the
things being equal when you've got sort
of these middling workers and relabeling
is more likely to be to be important and
then the final one is it really depends
on what your budget is so and depending
on what your budget is you might want to
do a very different strategy so as you
have more and more money to spend what
strategy do you think should dominate
how many people think you know labeling
how many people think as you got more
money we should get lots of people to
label things yeah that's what I thought
too but it's not as you have more and
more money actually unit
becomes better and better assuming that
you've got enough training data so why
is that so imagine that we've got a
bunch of training points and there's
some noise there intuitively what
happens is there's actually several
different classifier boundaries that are
consistent with that so we could go out
and ask to get these labels these data
points labeled multiple times if we do
we're going to get rid of all the noise
but we still actually can't distinguish
between those decision boundaries if
instead we go out and we get a lot more
data points then we still have noise but
actually because there's more points out
there it actually does a much better job
of of distinguishing between the
different classifiers so much more
formal argument in the paper if people
are interested but that's sort of the
intuition behind things so that's kind
of cool to characterize what's going on
but fundamentally it still leaves you
guys in a quandary like what exactly
should I do next time I'm actually
trying to crowdsource things you know
what should I stretch what should I do
what we'd like to do is have be nice if
there was like you didn't have to think
about it at all all you could do is use
our off-the-shelf labeling strategy and
that's going to figure it out
automatically
so what reactive learning does is is
like active learning in the sense that
use of the classifiers uncertainty to
figure out what data point I should
label but it considers data points that
have already been annotated and decides
should I get another label of that of
that data point and the first thing you
might do is you might say well let's use
some previously studied active learning
algorithm like uncertainty sampling and
if you try that it doesn't really work
very well uncertainty sampling basically
gets into infinite loops because it's
uncertain about example it just goes and
it asks I want more MORE no matter how
much data it can get about that example
it's never satisfied there's ways of
fixing uncertainty sampling so
that it never gets more than a certain
number of labels but now the question is
what's the parameter and so on so
uncertainty sampling by itself doesn't
work so well so again we can think about
this in terms of decision theory
question is which example should we
which examples should we get and without
going into the details the method that
we came up with is called impact
sampling and what we do is we consider a
set of labels and then we say well
suppose this label comes back as a
positive what's that going to do to my
classifier how many examples is that
going to cause to flip in terms of the
classifiers prediction suppose it
actually comes back as a negative how
many examples is it going to flip and
then what's the probability is going to
come as a positive or negative and I can
figure out what the expected impact is
of that of that labeling or relabeling
that data point and impact sampling
turns out to work work really really
well again there's a bunch of a bunch of
complicated things the way I've
described it it's it's a myopic strategy
and you can't have a myopic strategy
because suppose I've already gotten
three examples or four examples there
one more examples not necessarily going
to actually change the majority vote so
you need to sometimes think well maybe I
should get a couple more examples on
this thing so there's a way of doing
that without introducing combinatorial
search which we call pseudo look-ahead
which helps which helps enormously
without going into more details which
you can see here is that impact sampling
really works quite a bit better than any
of the other methods it is
computationally expensive so this method
is especially good when generating the
training data ziz is also expensive or
difficult to do and if you're in that
case this is this is a fantastic
technique some more examples where it
does it does well okay so in conclusion
what I've tried to argue is that this
sort of decision theoretic method using
partial observable
decision processes and reinforcement
learning is a really good way to think
about any crowd sourcing interaction and
tried to introduce that in the context
of a whole bunch of different workflows
where there's different kinds of choices
that the controller could make so it
could be what question to ask how many
times to ask it how much teaching should
we do how much testing should we do
should we actually ask a person to argue
or not you can imagine facing all of
these decisions using a distance
decision theoretic method and then as
you're doing it
decisions there you have to think what
your utility function is and they're
sort of two natural different utility
functions one is how good is your data
especially important for test data
the other one is forget about the data
what I really care about is how good is
the classifier that I'm learning and
then in general what we're interested in
is thinking about better ways of coming
up with tasks that allow people to do
with they're good at allow computers to
do with their I'm good at and come up
with these mixed initiative systems and
with that I will stop and see if there's
any questions Thank You mr. very humble
bells and whistle on your time that bit
detail but I think I'm missing the
intuition why is words the optimization
that you're doing much has the same
issues with with statements or assessing
for sourcing therefore on other degree
what does that you're saying yeah so
what this is doing is it's saying um
suppose I want to go back and label this
data point X if I if it came up as a
positive that would really swing my
classifier so that's why I really want
to make sure I've got the right label
but the the expected impact that's
weighted by how likely is it that it's
actually going to come up positive after
I've labeled it a whole bunch of times
and it's come up negative negative
negative negative then the chance that
is going to
positive is very very small and so it
becomes not worth my my trying to label
it again doing best at modeling of the
person in a certainty sampling the way
that works is it basically just says
yeah of all the examples what's the one
where I'm most confused and what that
usually does is it picks something
that's right squarely in the decision
boundary also tends to be oftentimes be
examples that are very hard for people
to label but you Joe
we just need at the time explain the
impact sample is it like deciding to
campaign more in Pennsylvania than in
California because the impact of
flipping a vote in Pennsylvania would
get me the outcome that I want with
that's exactly that's exactly what is
doing it doesn't it's not trying to win
the election but it's right it's that
that's intuitively it's trying to to
influence things yeah sorry I'm going to
switch to another slide yeah everybody
in terms of this vision of human and
hostage intelligence so what are the
ways that you think we're a team of this
discussion projects reinforcement
learning is it we saw were talking about
from this generate actions that we only
take on that you have seen one provides
more insight to what the function should
be optimized or you know what approach
ancestors and and maybe you found it
just is necessary is having humans
provide prior knowledge so I actually
have any core knowledge most what
actions try outward basic tools so I
think all of those are important and I'm
really interested in all of those I
think the decision theoretic methods
help you in some of them but maybe not
the most interesting ones so for example
I think really key thing is having the
people involve specify the utility
function or specify what the system is
trying to do I also think while
oftentimes the system knows what suppose
we have some objective the system knows
what actions are actually going to be
most effective towards that but in men
cases you don't want to actually tell
the person what to do maybe you want to
allow the person to do whatever the heck
they want to do because they're a person
and yet you still want to communicate to
them that this is where their efforts
are useful so I think there's some
interesting kinds of nudging techniques
or visualization techniques that can
guide people towards where they're most
effective but still give them the
freedom to do what it is they want to do
it's especially important when you've
got a bunch of experts as your as your
crowd workers yeah I love into the
insight of treating the instructions as
as valuable in the tasks I've always
sort of viewed crowdsourcing task design
as the user interface design problem
literally as you're designing user
name/password
for the people who are trying to achieve
it and it seems incredible that I would
you know I would I would never design an
interface for something I was going to
launch on the App Store there's launch
if that ever showed it to people but
this is what people want to do sometimes
with crowdsourcing and so I really like
this idea that I can that that it comes
back to me and I'm improving that this
interfaces I go and I wonder about you
gave one example which was around sort
of edge cases that I can think about
like is it is a cooked turkey a bird I'm
wondering about sort of instances the
classifier bias where it may be like
essentially there would be full
agreements but it wasn't actually what I
meant so maybe maybe intuitively
everyone would consider the yeah the
cartoon birds to be birds but that's not
actually what I intended I wonder if
there are ways to sort of catch that
kind of a situation early because that
one seems much harder to detect because
it seems like oh everyone everyone's
great and maybe I'm even hiding a
certain about it you know we have
examples where we're trying to annotate
webpages with their position on you know
marijuana legalization as an example and
if there's a newspaper article that's
reporting some pro-legalization argument
is that pro or is it just someone
reporting a pro event yeah it is because
of things like swing with very strong
confidence but or not at all what we
intended
I'm trying to think about how you can
capture that into the workflow as well
yeah I don't see if if there's no if
there's no ambiguity and then you're not
going to pick up any signal from the
workers and I don't see any way of
getting around that short of looking
over all of all of the data or looking
over a large sample of the data but in
all the examples I've seen in lots and
lots of tasks usually there is some
ambiguity and so some workers are
confused if I was confused and I hadn't
thought about it usually my instructions
are going to be unclear on that example
and so usually this kind of strategy
my belief is from that actually this
will pick it up although you know we
need to actually see say that again
all those are shallow I think that's a
reasonable a reasonable yeah that's a
good good summary learning approach
there's a lot I take the classifiers
that was generated and data and with
that finger to change parameters of the
Proxmire right because like are the
benefits still going to remain because
like usually get implied left electing
office lengthen like whether or not you
want to have multiple labels is like a
function of whether or not how well the
classifiers able to overfit on a data
right
yes oh I'm sorry I missed are you
talking about them the last part of the
talk the reactive learning I say your
question again because I was generated
if I take through this active learning
process that the datasets that was my
generated right and I changed
classifiers are the benefits relative to
to like just like the naive approach is
still going to remain um so yeah I think
that's a really interesting point it is
specific to the classifier architecture
and that's specifically the benefit of
it is that it's going to get the data
points which are best for that
particular classifier architecture if
you then switch to a much higher
dimensional classifier or much lower
dimensional classifier
and your data so it's not going to be
the optimal dataset anymore but I think
there is no optimal data set for there
is no optimal data set for all
classifiers and so you should have made
the right choice at the beginning or you
know you can actually I suppose you
could imagine extending this where it's
trying different classifier
architectures as as you go certainly the
data points are going to a good starting
point so you could start out with that
data and then train the different
classifier and have it get more it could
then decide I want to go back and real
able some things there's no reason why
you can't pick that up in the middle and
keep going the other questions a special
make have you ever considered it like
changing regards based on your feedback
I'll say work and see how much it
affects the result of wrestlers um so I
think that there's a huge number of
things that one can do in terms of
changing the incentives and there
definitely are a number of people who
have looked at that we haven't really
done we haven't looked at that whole
dimension and I think there's actually a
lot of probably very strong interactions
between some of the things we have
studied and the incentive process so
yeah much much more stuff to be done yep
so about have you have any really like
unsupervised or cements provide problems
where you the labels themselves are not
please find you know they are actually
variable as you discover them like
social science likely to become a
psychology schema that he'll defined and
as you get more data your study findings
better better so the label becomes more
precise and you actually see more data
it feels very hard to get like lots of
data and lots of label so there's you
know once a cousin who has enough time
to make I don't care like problem I can
just provide the services right yeah so
I think that that's it's a really
interesting problem I think the part of
our work that comes closest to that as
the self improving instructions again
where we use the
sort of structured labeling process to
try to identify where there's
ambiguities in the in the labeling
process and then refine that but yeah
okay great well thank you everybody
appreciate it
[Applause]
you